bien estamos en el problema número 16 y
bueno parecer que es el último vídeo de
esta sección así que venga tengo algo
por aquí tengo un par de ex condenados
algo más o menos así y tengo el otro más
o menos así ok
este es el eje y este es el eje x y me
dan la función a la gráfica de una
palabra así que voy a intentar dibujarla
con este color tengo una parábola más o
menos así está este punto y después a
baja y después baja por aquí más o menos
así y bueno a además de esta palabra me
dicen que por aquí este valor de 1 por
aquí está el valor de 1 y me dicen que
la función cuadrática h por cierto esta
es h hdx ok am se muestra en la
siguiente gráfica y toma su mayor valor
en hd 2 es decir que este punto el punto
donde está más alto déjame cambiar de
color el punto donde está más alta en
parábola es h 2 aquí es hd 2 y por lo
tanto aquí aquí
es el valor de 2 ok y después me dicen a
que para hd hd a es igual a 0 ok h de am
es igual a 0
ok eso quiere decir que puede ser este
punto aquí si te das cuenta este es el
punto en donde mi función se hace cero o
este punto de que puede ser este valor o
este valor ok a lo que me preguntan de
hecho es cuánto vale pues los siguientes
valores podría ser un valor válido para
ok y date cuenta que el exceso a dice
menos uno menos uno y es que aquí
podemos utilizar simetría
pensemos un poco menos uno menos uno si
podría ser un valor válido para porque
está después del cero y bueno se ve
claramente no está en básica que puede
cruzar por un valor negativo después
dice b igual a cero b igual a cero esa
no puede ser mi respuesta porque de
hecho en la gráfica se ve luego luego
que mi parábola cruzan por un valor
negativo
o sea un valor negativo o un valor que
esté después de 2 por lo tanto 0 0 no
puede ser mi respuesta correcta porque
por aquí no pasa mi parábola se dice 22
bueno 2 no puede ser mi valor ha valido
para am porque 2 es un valor máximo de
esta parábola y si te das cuenta como
esta gráfica esta parábola 2 el valor
que está más arriba no es el valor en
donde cruza al eje de las x 3
3 y 4 dice el inciso d y el inciso y
aparece que mi respuesta es el inciso a
y fíjate bien justo aquí es donde voy a
utilizar la ley de la simetría de la
parábola si este es el punto más alto el
punto máximo
máximo entonces a la distancia que hay
de aquí hasta acá es una unidad dos
unidades
y otro cachito más no sabemos cuántas
unidades más pero lo que sí sé es que al
menos hay dos unidades hay más de dos
unidades y por simetría esta parábola va
a cruzar al eje de las equis en la misma
distancia de este punto de este punto
máximo del lado izquierdo que del lado
derecho es decir que la distancia que
hay de aquí acá a ver pongamos la con
otro color la distancia que hay de aquí
hasta acá esta distancia por simetría de
la parábola debe de ser igual a esta
instancia de aquí deben de ser iguales
estas dos distancias y por lo tanto
esta distancia es mayor que dos unidades
entonces ésta también debe de ser mayor
de dos unidades más grande que dos
unidades más grande que dos unidades y
por lo tanto no puede ser tres y no
puede ser cuatro porque tres y cuatro
están a una distancia menor o igual a
dos unidades y tiene que ser más grande
que dos unidades porque se nota que
corte en un valor negativo por lo tanto
no puede ser cero no puede ser dos no
puede ser tres y no puede ser cuatro
tiene que ser un valor más grande que
cuatro hampones lo que a o es un valor
negativo o en su dado caso debe ser un
valor mayor que cuatro y entre todos mis
incisos a la única respuesta válida es
el inciso amp que me dice que vale menos
1 es decir un valor negativo 3 y 4 no
funcionan porque están a una distancia
más pequeña que el otro valor de la
intersección cuando elegidas x y por lo
tanto mi respuesta es el inciso
a menos uno ok problema número dieciséis
vamos a el problema número diecisiete y
bueno solamente es cuestión de que
repases un poco la cuestión de las
parábolas es importante que entiendan
muy bien las funciones cuadráticas son
muy útiles dice tenemos la función x
cuadrada más k x + 7 esto es igual a x +
1 por x + h donde h ica son constantes y
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale k
cuánto vale está atrás este valor de
aquí voy ok pues lo bloque se me ocurre
es desarrollar esta parte de aquí esta
parte de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
que éste por este más este por éste y
después este x es triste por esto es
decir x cuadrada x cuadrada
h x y después voy a multiplicar este por
este y este por este más a x + h ok y
del otro lado lo voy a dejar igual como
x cuadrada más acá por x + 7 ok de aquí
si te das cuenta tengo un factor común
con x entonces voy a factorizar a x y me
quedan x cuadrada más y voy a factorizar
a x y me queda x que multiplica h y x
que multiplica a 1
ok más h ok y bueno esto porque porque
aquí me está diciendo y esto es lo
importante de este problema si estas dos
expresiones son iguales esto es igual a
x cuadrada más k x
7 si estas dos expresiones son iguales
eso quiere decir ahí vamos a tomar
colores distintos que el valor o el
coeficiente que está al lado de la equis
cuadrada debe de ser igual a este
coeficiente que está lado de la equis
cuadrada que por cierto se cumple es uno
por aquí y uno por acá estos los
coeficientes deben de ser iguales pero
además el coeficiente que está al lado
de la x debe de ser igual al coeficiente
que está al lado de la x es decir que
acá debe de ser igual a h más uno y
además de eso se debe cumplir que el
coeficiente libre debe ser exactamente
igual para que éste cumple esta igualdad
no me queda de otra
aquí me está diciendo que h debe de ser
igual a 7 este de aquí debe ser igual a
este de kim después nos fijamos en
quienes son los que están al lado de la
x h más uno debe ser igual acá debe ser
igual a k h más uno debe ser igual acá y
por último a bueno uno tiene que ser
igual a uno pero eso se cumple uno debe
ser igual a uno y no lo voy a escribir
y si vale 7
entonces ya puede obtener el valor de
campo que es igual a 7 + 1 lo cual es 8
lo único que hice fue sustituir el valor
de h justo aquí entonces ya tengo que
acá vale 8 que es justo lo que quiere
encontrar el valor de cam acá vale 8 es
la respuesta de este problema de este
problema número 17 ok pues vamos a hacer
el siguiente problema problema número 17
que lo único que teníamos que hacer era
igualar los coeficientes semejantes
vamos el problema número 18 18 y tengo a
un plano canciano así que déjenme
cambiar un color un poco más
llamativo tengo aquí mayer y por aquí mi
eje x este es mi game ok este es mi eje
x y tengo una recta como por aquí a una
renta parecida a ésta ok
algo más o menos así y después tengo un
triángulo un triángulo que forman con
o así y algo así ok y me dicen que es el
triángulo y le voy a poner nombre de una
vez
cm y además me dicen que esta recta pasa
por este punto de aquí este punto de
aquí que es el punto 4 2 1 perdón es el
punto 4,10
4,10 eso quiere decir que para este
valor de x para este de aquí a 4
vale 10 en esta recta este valor vale 10
ok este es el valor 4,10 y porque todo
esto bueno porque lo que es el problema
es lo siguiente en la figura siguiente
los lados del triángulo hace y se ve es
decir que este lado y este lado son
paralelos a los ejes ok eso es muy
importante este lado y este lado son
paralelos a los ejes lo que quiere decir
que este ángulo es de 90 grados aunque
cuáles de los siguientes números podrían
ser los lados del triángulo a b c
ok y bueno la clave de este problema es
fijándose en que este es un triángulo
rectángulo lo sabemos además de que es
un triángulo rectángulo me voy a fijar
que está sobre esta recta y esta recta y
de hecho no puedo sacar su ecuación o
inclusive por sacar su pendiente y lo
que preocupar es la pendiente de esta
recta la pendiente de esta recta y como
la encuentro la pendiente es igual a 10
menos 0 lo cual es 10 entre 4 - 0 lo
cual es 4 es decir el cambio en jake con
respecto al cambio en x lo cual es a 10
entre 4 son cinco medios o esto es muy
importante lo que me está diciendo es
que la relación de x con i es de 5
medios o dicho de otra manera que por
cada una unidad que yo avance en x voy a
avanzar 5 medios en yemen o mejor aún si
yo avanzo de aquí acá en x a una cierta
cantidad le voy a poner x entonces esta
cantidad que voy a avanzar en yemen es
decir ésta que voy a subir es 5 medios
el valor de esta cantidad es decir 5
medios de x eso es lo que me es la
pendiente si yo camino para acá una
cierta cantidad bueno pues lo que voy a
subir es la pendiente multiplicada por
esa misma cantidad el cambio en ye con
respecto a x y bueno aquí podemos
obtener la hipotenusa pero qué te parece
si obtenemos a los valores más sencillos
que se me ocurran para esta recta
imagínate qué x valga si quiero fijarme
a ver veamos los incisos el inciso a
mediaset 25 y raíz de no sé qué 2 aunque
yq si x vale
2x vale 2 entonces cuando sustituyó aquí
me va a quedar 5 medios por 2 lo cual es
el 2002 cancela y me quedaría solamente
5 es decir que uno de los lados podría
valer 2 y el otro podría valer 5 y ya
con estos dos lados podríamos obtener el
valor de esta parte de aquí de la
hipotenusa recuerda que la hipotenusa es
la raíz cuadrada de este elevado al
cuadrado es decir 4 más este elevado al
cuadrado es decir 25 es decir que en
este caso la hipotenusa debería de valer
a raíz de 29 que por cierto es el inciso
a el cis ahora me dice 2,5 como raíz de
29 y está del lujo porque ya cumple los
tres lados 1 vale 2 el otro vale
5 y el otro por el teorema de pitágoras
debe de valer raíz de 29 por ejemplo si
te das cuenta en el inciso b en el sis
ope dice
257 y eso no es cierto porque no
estarían diciendo que no no sabemos el
teorema de pitágoras si este lado vale 2
y este lado vale 5 este lado debe de
valer raíz de 29 por el teorema de
pitágoras y ya está aquí lo importante
fue fijarnos en esta pendiente está
pendiente es muy importante para
entender la relación entre los lados
bueno problema número 18 vamos por los
dos últimos a un problema número 19
problema número 19 dice si la función fx
fx está definida como 2 x menos 1 ok y
tenemos que un medio un medio efe dt es
igual a 1 no lo es efe es f de la raíz
de t de la raíz de esto es igual a 4
entonces lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale t bueno pues primero veamos que nos
ft
efe de la raíz de t efe es la raíz de t
es igual a dos veces la raíz de t
la raíz de menos uno lo único que estoy
haciendo es aplicando esta función para
x igual a la raíz de tema esto es
sustituyendo a x y en lugar de x estoy
poniendo la raíz de t ok y si a esto lo
multiplicó por un medio tienes un medio
efe de la raíz de t de la raíz de tema
bueno pues es esto por un medio y aquí
me quedaría y lo voy a poner así
un medio que multiplica todo esto de
aquí a dos veces las raíces de tm - y ok
un medio que multiplica todo esto que
está aquí y ahora voy a utilizar el dato
que me dan dicen que esto es igual a 4
así que lo voy a poner justo aquí esto
de aquí es exactamente lo mismo que 4
ahora fíjate bien tenemos esta ecuación
de aquí y qué te parece si de esta
ecuación de aquí despejamos el valor de
t lo único que hay que hacer es tener
mucho cuidado con nuestras operaciones y
para esto a qué te parece multiplico
todo por 2 2 por 1 medio a estos medios
se van porque 2 por un medio es 1 y me
va a quedar solamente que dos veces la
raíz de t menos 1 esto es igual a 8 con
dicho otra manera dos veces la raíz de t
es igual a 9 por dicho otra manera la
raíz de t es igual a 9 entre 2 o dicho
de otra manera
es igual a 9 entre 2 y con esta raíz
cuadrada lo que voy a hacer es elevar
ambos miembros de esta igualdad al
cuadrado no va a quedar el cuadrado de
esto la raíz con el cuadrado se van y
aquí me queda nueve medios elevado al
cuadrado que por cierto que es igual a
81 cuartos y 81 cuartos es mi insisto
de lujo
19 ya está
y tenemos que despejar el tema y ya no
queda mucho tiempo así que voy a
intentar hacer el problema número 20
vamos a ver si lo logro al menos el
bozar dice si acá es un entero positivo
cuál de los siguientes incisos
representa un entero par que es el
dobles donde entero en par o no el doble
de un entero palin para ver acá acá es
un entero
entero positivo positivo
ok como represento primero me dice un
entero par bueno sí que es un entero
positivo no sé si sea para el par pero
de lo que sí estoy segurísimo es que dos
veces acá más uno
este es un entero impar
este es un entero impar y yo lo que
busco es un entero en parte sea cual sea
el valor de camps se apartó impar dos
camas uno es un entero en par y tú
puedes hacer la prueba si acá vale uno
dos tres vas a ver que siempre el
resultado es un entero impar dos veces
un entero es par y esto sumamos uno me
va a dar impar de lujo y ahora lo que
quiero es el doble de este interín para
el doble desde entonces para tomarme el
doble de éste lo que ves es multiplicar
esto por dos dos veces a dos k más uno
esto es igual a 4 veces acá más 2 y este
es un entero par es surreal entero par
porque a un entero lo estoy duplicando
el duplicado se vuelve par
es el doble también por ciento es el
doble de este el doble ok y cuatro camas
dos están mis respuestas como el inciso
e de lujo ya está mi respuesta si tengo
un entero positivo entonces dos camas
uno forzosamente es un entero o impar y
dos veces esto es un entero par que es
el doble este entero en par que es justo
lo que yo quería no pierdas la
oportunidad de hacerlo por ti mismo y
comprobar que su cierto así que nos
vemos en la siguiente sección